in a previous video we start to get an
intuition for rate curves and what the
area under a rate curve represents so
for example this rate curve this might
represent the speed of a car and how the
speed of a car is changing with respect
to time and so this shows us that our
rate is actually changing this isn't
distance as a function of time this is
rate as a function of time so this looks
like the car is accelerating at time one
it is going 10 meters per second and at
time 5 let's say let's assume that all
of these are in seconds so at 5 seconds
it is going 20 meters per second so it
is accelerating now the relationship
between the rate function and the area
is that if we're able to figure out this
area then that is the change in distance
of the car so rate or speed in this case
is distance per unit time if we're able
to figure out the area under that curve
it will actually give us our change in
distance from time 1 to time 5 it won't
tell us our total distance because we
don't we won't know what happened before
time 1 if we're not concerned with that
area and the intuition for that it's a
little bit easier if you were dealing
with rectangles but just think about
this let's make a rectangle that looks
like a pretty good approximation for the
area let's say from time one to time two
right over here well what is this area
of this rectangle represent we would to
figure out the area we would multiply
one second that would be the width here
times roughly it looks like about 10
meters per second and so the units here
would be 10 meters per second times 1
second or 10 meters and we know from
early physics or even before that if you
multiply a rate times time or a speed
times a time you're going to get a
distance and so the unit here is in
distance and as you can see this area is
going to represent its are gonna be an
approximation for the distance traveled
and so if you wanted to get an exact
version or an exact number for the
distance traveled you would get the
exact area under the curve and we have a
notation for that
if you want the exact area under the
curve right over here we use definite
integral notation this area right over
here we could denote as a definite
integral from 1 to 5 of R of T DT and
once again what does this represent in
this case when our rate is speed this
represents this whole expression
represents our change in distance from T
is equal to 1 to T is equal to 5
now with that context let's actually try
to do an example problem the type that
you might see on Khan Academy so this
right over here tells us even walked at
a rate of R of T kilometers per hour
where T is the time in hours okay so now
T is in hours what does the integral
from the definite integral from 2 to 3
of our of T DT equals 6 mean so before I
even look at these choices this is
saying so this is going from T equals
two hours to T equals three hours and
it's essentially the area under the rate
curve and here the rate is we're talking
about a speed Eden is walking at a
certain number of kilometres per hour
so what this means is that from time to
hours to time three hours
Eden walked an extra six kilometers so
let's see which of these choices match
that Eden walked six kilometers each
hour it does tell us that from time to
two three
Eden walked six kilometers but doesn't
just mean but we don't know what
happened from time 0 to time 1 or from
time one to time two so I would rule
this out
Eden walked 6 kilometers in three hours
so this is a common misconception people
will look at the top bound and say okay
the this is this area represent by the
definite integral this tells us how far
in total we have walked up until that
point that is not what this represents
this represents the change in distance
from time - to time 3 so I'll rule that
out
edan walked six kilometers during the
third hour yes that's what we've been
talking about from time to equals hours
from time equal to hours to time equal
three hours edan walk six kilometers and
you could view that as the third hour
going from time to to time three Eden's
rate increased by six kilometers per
hour but between hours 2 & 3 so let's be
very clear this right over here this
isn't a rate this is the area under the
rate curve that's what this definite
integral is representing and so this
isn't telling us about our rate changing
this is telling us how does the thing
that the rate is measuring the change of
how does that change from time to time 3
so we would rule that out as well